Swedish historian Johan Norberg
is the author of The Capitalist
Manifesto: Why the Global
Free Market Will Save the World,
which caught the eye of Elon Musk,
who recently tweeted: "this book,
is an excellent explanation of why
capitalism is not just successful
but morally right." Norberg
wrote the book to combat a growing
belief on the right and the left
that libertarian values of
individual autonomy, property
rights, limited government and free
enterprise are failing
to raise living standards and need
to be ditched in favor of more
centralized power and control
over virtually all aspects
of our lives.
A senior fellow at the Cato
Institute, Norberg, shows that life
is actually getting better for all
of us, especially the world's poor,
and that economic globalization,
political liberalization and
cultural freedom are the main
drivers of improvement.
Johan Norberg.
Thanks for talking to Reason.
Pleasure's all mine.
First off, let's start.
What's the elevator pitch?
Or do Swedes call it the
lift  in English? What do you go
with? Is it a lift or an elevator?
We call it a hiss.
A hiss. Okay.
What is it?
What is the hiss pitch?
You know, for the capitalist
manifesto?
Well, the his pitch is that,
you know, we have wide discontent
with capitalism and free
markets and free trade.
It seems like politicians
on all continents have all agreed
that we need to repatriate
production, redistribute
resources, that inequality
and global warming shows us that
that free markets doesn't work.
And my point is that on
each of us in every area,
free markets, entrepreneurs,
innovators have performed
spectacularly well
and that most of these things
have been misunderstood.
And even in the 21st
century, I mean,
the past 20 years or
so have been pretty good, even
though there's a lot of people that
you and I have kind of been allies
with ideologically over the years
who are like, Oh yeah, yeah, it was
great up until 2000 and now
it's all gone to shit.
Let's start by talking about yeah,
it was like about 20 years ago that
you and I, I think first talked and
you were pushing a book called
In Defense of Global Capitalism.
Kind of sketch out what were
the circumstances that book
needed to be manifested.
Well, they were the same as they
are today.
Politicians and interest
groups blamed global
capitalism and free trade for all
the problems of the world.
Back then, a leftist
current of
anti-globalization and
reducing free trade
around the world.
And I thought I had to gather
the argument because I thought that
was I was seeing around the world
was that the very countries that
began to integrate into the global
economy, they did better than they
had ever done before.
Poverty was decreasing,
opportunities were improving
and cutting
them off from globalization destroy
that.
Yeah. What were the big arguments
emanating? And I mean, it was
I guess it was center
and center from
the center going towards the left,
especially the right wing seemed to
be, at least in America, was
broadly supportive of globalization
and trade. And, you know, George
H.W. Bush had started
NAFTA.
Bill Clinton, who was a centrist
Democrat, you know, finished the job
and everything. But, you know, we
were high off of winning the Cold
War.
But by the end of the decade, you
had people dressing like sea turtles
and smashing Starbucks and
McDonald's in Seattle.
What was the main complaint
coming from the anti-globalization
then?
Well, it wasn't portrayed as a
justice movement.
The very idea that, yes,
multinational companies
and big brands and free trade,
they might benefit us in the rich
world, but it will come at a
terrible cost in poor countries
exploitation, widening inequalities,
increasing poverty.
So basically a zero sum idea
about how the world works.
If we benefit, they will lose.
And ironically, I
get the same thing today, but
the positions have been reversed.
Okay. Yeah, let's talk about that
because yeah, I mean, you flash
forward 20, 20 years
or so and it seems like it's more
right wingers are now saying, you
know what, we need to nail
down the borders.
We need to build more walls.
Globalization benefits
these global, you know,
corporations, not the little guy.
Quite right. And actually,
they sound very much like
'attack the 20 years ago, this
fringe left wing protectionist
organization.' But now from a
right wing nationalist
perspective and in a way, they have
the same idea that the world
is a zero sum game.